Steelers and the Dolphins coming up
wildcard weekend Ben how's your morale
very good how's yours I hear you sound
like you have little bit of a cold yeah
but you know what the great ones play
like everyday Superbowl right yeah
that's that's very true not almost more
sweatpants to work though doing it you'd
like to wait you can wear sweatpants
right there's no joking we know we wear
sweatpants on the sideline if I buy your
producer I had to make fun your
sweatpants
oh okay Paulie set me up they're nice do
you remember your draft profile of
things that may have bothered you when
you're first coming out of Miami of Ohio
no I don't Pauly do you have Ben's draft
profile there yes big arm passer poise
under pressure
terrific pump fake but then the bad was
needs to improve footwork release and
does not throw the tightest spirals is
that okay you're okay yeah do you
remember your 40 time I know I think my
the best I ran was like four seven five
or something four seven eight yeah four
seven five you were you deceptively you
were deceptively fast weren't you I
couldn't break five right now I don't
think could you beat Rich Eisen in a
40-yard dash right now yes what
quarterback could you beat right now
40-yard dash starting court could you be
Brady um I I think so I think we both
might give up we could make it a 30 yard
dash not a 40-yard dash if that but I
might be able to Philip Rivers he's in
my draft class in Eli it'd be a good
race between our two draft class guys oh
I like me like how important though is
you know we talked about the Hall of
Fame this time of the year at what point
have you or will you start thinking
about that probably I get done you know
it's it's something that is an awesome
honor obviously congrats to Alan Faneca
one of my old teammates who
made the finalist list so you know it's
just it's just something you have to
think when you're done I don't want to
think about it now because I don't want
to I feel like I got a lot more to do
playing this game so when I'm done
that's something that all coming to mind
I guess I remember getting into a real
heated discussion with Alan Faneca and I
was sticking up for you this is when you
were a rookie and I think Alan said
something about you know I guess we're
gonna have to go with the rookie and I
criticized him to say that's not the way
you want to embrace your quarterback and
I don't know if you remember that but
fanuc has said something in the locker
room that I had a problem with that I I
just didn't feel like that he was
embracing you as the starting
quarterback you remember that absolutely
and Alan and I just still joke about
that today obviously we can laugh about
it now but yeah I might remember that
and you know that that meant a lot you
know kind of coming from a guy that I
looked up to as a leader and a guy that
was a leader on this team
it hurt but I also understood where he
was coming from I knew that he was
really close with um with Tommy and you
know he's a guy that wanted to go in and
knew that we had a really good team and
didn't think that a young rookie
quarterback could help so I understood I
guess where he was coming from
so she planned this game as long as I
have now and and you know what it was
its kind of water to the bridge now
since we went and did it he's Ben
Roethlisberger's Steelers quarterback
Dolphins coming to town I went back and
was looking at that game when you guys
went to Miami and the Dolphins were
really struggling what do you remember
about that game that sort of turned
their season around yeah you know we
didn't we didn't have a really good
football team I mean they're there their
defensive line gets after there we made
a lot of mistakes on offense and a lot
of mental errors and they created by
them we didn't play well and that's the
game that I remember I I tore my
meniscus in and tried to play the second
half and just wasn't a fun experience
that second half but that was in Dominic
and Sue cheap shot well that's one later
in the game he kicked me in my good bad
news did you say anything to him no
because I you know at the time I didn't
know exactly what happened I just knew
that I felt this pain in my knee and I
thought I knew what happened but I
wasn't sure until I saw it on film so
what injury do you think you're gonna
feel
20 years from now oh boy I always worry
about the knees I hope that like in 20
years maybe less whenever I need you
know the new knee I hope it's just like
an outpatient surgery like going to the
dentist they kind of put you out you
walked out opened it we would get that
far that fast I figure at some point my
knees are going to be hurting and you
know anybody throws as much as you know
I quarter back does or a pitcher does
you you always worry about elbow and
shoulder so I guess that's one two
especially cuz I want to play catch with
my kids you know for as long as I can
can your kids just gonna play football
if they want to I'm not gonna tell them
they can't I will encourage my kids to
do whatever they want to do and love to
doing and I'll help them with whatever
it is hopefully it's golf though could
you teach your style would you teach
your style to a quarterback um well it
depends on what you mean by my style I
mean I think like standing to play I
mean you take a lot of hits but that
that style is is kind of unique in the
NFL yeah I mean also I've been sacked
second lease in the NFL this year you
know and that obviously is a credit to
my line and just you know learning to
play the game different as you get older
but you know when you say the style like
extending plays I think that is much to
do with like heart and determination and
not giving up as a particular style you
know I'm not I don't drop back to pass
and say okay on this play I want to
scramble or I'm going to do this I'm
gonna try and make this play it's just
out of necessity it's out of trying not
to give up on a play but I watch those
games on Sunday with Rodney Harrison and
Tony Dungy and they'll say the same
thing
don't let Ben go right and then somebody
will eventually allow you to go right or
you go right extend to play and make a
big play if we know what's going to
happen why is it that the defense
doesn't or can't stop that cuz I want
them to make me go left because I like
throwing to my left better wait all
these years they were there wrong the
scouting reports wrong you like going
left I do because no one's expecting it
so now the Dolphins know you like going
left that that's that could change the
game coming up this weekend
the the biggest offer you got out of
high school aside from Miami of Ohio was
where her football yeah I depends on who
I i depends on who got offers from a lot
of schools how state Michigan's a lot of
Big Ten schools some SEC ACC's to play
court house the biggest though a little
bit of both you know I think it was you
know you now especially looking back you
realize you get the letters everyone
wants to offer you you never know what
you're gonna be till you get there I
know there were rumblings that Ohio
State wanted to make me a tight end
because I played receiver my junior year
you know but it just it felt right with
Coach Hefner in Miami but if you did it
again you know it seems like kids want
to go to a bigger program but they also
the opportunity to be able to play right
away do you think you'd make the same
decision I do I love my my time in Miami
cuz that was something I looked at too
they had a senior quarterback I would
get to like sit behind for my redshirt
year and they can get a chance to play
at least compete to play and that's all
I asked for was a chance to compete and
I got that chance with Coach happen
I loved him to death that that
relationship that we had and I still
have with his family they are family to
me so it's invaluable and I wouldn't
change that and or my experience for the
world how much should we care about what
you guys do in your off day and the
reason why I bring it up with the Giants
and you don't have to talk about the
Giants if you don't want to but the wide
receivers were in Miami after beating
Washington on their their day off how
much should we care or know about that I
don't you know I think it's a it's your
day off you know we don't we don't care
what what you're doing on your day off
you know it's just like I spend my days
off with my family you know is that
that's the point of a day off you should
be able to clear your mind because this
is such a grueling and taxing job both
mentally and physically that if you get
it day you should be able to do what
kind of clears your mind and clears your
body and get you ready to go back to
work to be at 100% both mentally and
physically just public perception matter
it always does doesn't it I mean that's
that's especially in a society we live
in now with all the Twitter's and
instagrams and all the things they have
now that I know nothing about you know I
think public perception is a big deal
for people how do you keep it loose in
the huddle laughs tell jokes smile just
you know in that moment that you know
I'm out there whether it was from you
know during a timeout or something
talk about someone that's in the stand
or talking about a defender make fun of
somebody just just keep it loose how did
you guys react when you heard what
Bradshaw said about coach Tomlin was
that an important topic in the locker
room not to me I laughed about it I'm
used to you know people just saying
whatever you have to just kind of let it
go dust in the wind kind of thing no
Kansas ref reference there and the ice
what do you listen to that might
surprises I'm a I love old like like 70s
and 80s music love like Billy Joel
anything that's just kind of more
relaxing when I know people know when
I'm in the weight room because I put on
they're like oh boy Ben's in here we got
Billy Joel playing we've got Elton John
playing you've got buddy Tyrone wells
playing just more mellow music and they
want to put on something a little more
extreme and I know I'm in there and I
got seniority so we'll make the
Superbowl if what we win all our games
with nice nice nap I love that yeah
that's a motto to live by
well good luck this weekend we
appreciate you are joining us thanks
thanks again absolutely my pleasure and
I hope you feel better
Thank You Ben thank you the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
[Music]